[Musica]
la musica voi quando andate i concerti
ascoltate con quel meraviglioso organo
che noi abbiamo l'udito voi ascoltate la
musica come ascoltate la musica ha
scontato un discorso che fa qualcuno
però ben sapete che spesso noi stiamo
scontando qualcuno però stiamo pensando
altrove succede la stessa cosa con la
musica la musica
voi lo mettete in casa per fare i lavori
di casa di fa da colonna sonora mentre
fatto un viaggio però non sentite la
musica quella cosa meravigliosa cambiamo
noi nel nostro corpo nel nostro fisico
che è il sentire le vibrazioni che la
musica da ed è per questo che a me
piacerebbe con voi condividere questo
sentire della musica e mi piacerebbe
tanto che vuoi a un certo punto mi
dimostrate che anche voi come noi
agonisti in questo caso della musica
sentite come noi la musica la musica
dentro di noi ce l'avete da quando siamo
nati
nella pancia della nostra mamma
sapete noi
sentiamo il cuoricino il cuoricino
nostro poi man mano che che cresciamo i
suoni che se vengono dati da fuori
al di là di tutte le viscere lì le cose
questo muovono in pancia tutto quello e
il ritmo tutto quello che sa un sono
suoni con cui noi cresciamo a questo io
mi riferisco quando dico di sentire la
musica e non soltanto ascoltare
la musica perché la musica ce l'abbiamo
tutti la musica c'è nel vento
se nel passo quando camminiamo c'è il
ritmo
no questo è un remo che poi diventa
anche un balletto noi balliamo ma da
dove venivano parliamo di un passo e
questo sì vogliamo andare nella storia
dell'umanità nella storia della musica
tutto viene da
questi signori che sono la nostra
diciamo antenati i nostri antenati che
con il femore di un mammut hanno
iniziato a crudo ma dream brown e
l'altro iniziato a fare il passetto e da
lì sono nati balle sono nati i ritmi che
poi portarono nel corso della storia
dell'umanità alla musica che oggi come
ben sapete si è voluta ma se nel vento
c'è nella pioggia c'è in ogni elemento
che ci circonda ed è per questo che io
considero che non ci siano confini
rispettando il tema di questa sera non
ci si era confine tra il tecnico e il
biologico la musica ce l'abbiamo tutti
questa è una considerazione molto
personale però che ho constatato con
tanti allievi che ha avuto nel corso
della mia carriera signore dimostro
adesso un fatto di sentire la musica
rispetto alle elementi della natura gli
elementi che abbiamo dentro ho
dimostrato il passo un vento una pioggia
e capite quanta musica c'è intorno a noi
ma non ce ne siamo mai accorti perché si
voi e studiate ascoltate sentite la
musica venete anche a conoscenza delle
qualità
interiori
biologiche che vi ha concesso la natura
che semplicemente non avete
sviluppato
questo è una considerazione
personalissima che adesso vi porterò
a dimostrare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io vi consiglio
mi piacerebbe
caso vi liberate
[Musica]
appoggiate per terra e tutte le borse
sedetevi e dritti
[Musica]
dipendete le bracce
proprio per aria per aria sedute
e non intorno al corpo intorno al corpo
così
[Musica]
esatto
chiudete gli occhi e
sentite la musica
immaginate il panorama che volete ma
sentite
[Musica]
come è stato il viaggio
a questo mi riferisco quando dico di
sentire la musica non di ascoltarla
fisicamente e basta a questo mi
riferisco sapete noi abbiamo dei battiti
cardiaci che hanno delle velocità no bpm
si chiamano battiti per minuti a seconda
della velocità di un brano ci porta in
una sensazione un'emozione o un'altra ed
è per questo che è importante quando si
è sotto ansia mettere un pezzo lento di
stesso o quando ci si vuole caricare
quando si sia in palestra mentre diversi
magari un pelino più carichi ed è per
questo che a me piacerebbe adesso
dimostrare a voi e che questi limiti non
si sono nella musica sono solo delle
scelte chi sceglie di seguire la musica
per mestiere lavoro approfondendo
tecnica teoricamente che c'è invece chi
preferisce solo tenerla come diletto
come ben sapete la musica è ovunque c'è
nella nostra quotidianità ci sono negli
eventi nelle cerimonie matrimoni e
battesimi feste di compleanno
c'è nel tutte le campagne politiche se
non ci fosse un inno non c'è non ci
sarebbe una campagna politica magari con
cui ci possiamo riconoscere o piuttosto
le religioni un giorno faceva una
battuta con un amico immagine al mondo
senza musica immagina il mondo persino
la chiesa
immagina la chiesta se insicuri senza
tutte le sue messe con la musica e
questo amico questo collega maurice
poste non ci crederebbe nessuno la
chiesa senza musica non ci crederebbe
nessuno ed è per quello che io considero
che la musica fa parte di tutti noi e io
invito a voi a sentire la musica perché
non ci sono limiti ci sono delle
barriere culturale per cui siamo nati in
una o un'altra geografia ma oggi quei
limiti non ci sono più ed è per questo
che io vorrei portarvi adesso su questo
lato diciamo
chiamamolo teorico e mi piacerebbe che
voi con me
facesti
questo che io determino la dimostrazione
del che quello che è stato detto stasera
è stato da voi assorbito e voi vi
dimostrerete che così è stato
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e allora
[Musica]
preferisco
a questo è merito
avete dimostrato che avete sentito la
politica e poi l'ha detto prima
avete sentito grazie a venezia grazie
mentre
grazie
[Musica]